okay anyway the point is she's retired
she's 50 and they went to her and said
what are you doing and she goes I just
want to go to sleep I'm just so tired
and set and pathetic and they're like
we'll give you $5 million to do a show
once a week I guess fine that's what
she's doing that's why she's pattering
on the show that's why she's just she's
she she's going like Donald Trump wants
to be president that means he'll run for
president and no matter what you think
about that he's going to tell his
supporters he's running for president so
you might not want to be president but
he's going to run and you know what that
means he'll tell his supporters he's
running no matter what it is you think
that's literally what she did man this
lady's off the off her Rock wild also
she's getting paid millions of dollars
to do this like what a sweet gig guys I
don't know what to tell you what are
they going to do fire her I mean if
MSNBC doesn't have a network without
Rachel mattow I I couldn't name another
uh MSNBC host to be honest with you Ian